hello and welcome to this video playing
acid or off he dressed you three year no
isn't this person who plays a d3 f3 and
stuff maybe I'm confusing him with
somebody very likely H Israel I have to
watch out form c4 in this position is b7
is hanging so I'm going c6
I wonder if e6 is a move in this
position I know maybe I also could have
taken like c4 Knight backend
[Music]
III it's not exactly a very developing
way of playing it so to see does he keep
the poor near Quincy seven wonder about
this yam if he goes into d6 this is okay
currently g7 is hanging is what I'm
trying to say not very successfully
ciao g6 is not a move that you want to
play early
get a pawn on d6 that can be both the
weakness and oil strength I mean in 96 I
expect him to play no doesn't do it
the ship G 796 strolling so strongly bit
too much
yeah I'm partisan too slow here with the
doors so I would be five I'm keeping
this this knight on d5 for the time
being the problem is that is hit King
position the King position looks bad I
mean really bad
you
try to get to the pawn - between
I don't get to that friggin pawn
should be too I want to collect p8 maybe
you can SEC the exchange I still have
six available I'm not there I was a
stupid game what is stupid game I'll
give black very nice and the thing is I
don't even believe in this stuff h3
shouldn't really be good really I mean
like everybody Class B should be too and
I don't quite believe in this move but
it's not that doesn't seem to be an
obvious problem with it I mean I am
making the computer eval yes not doesn't
make much sense but I mean white came up
B plus one in this position this is just
not not true but maybe I can still
improve somehow by doing this this
irritated me but I have night before of
course yeah this day I overlooked this
opportunity so I have to take that's
better than so it's a little bit a
little bit better and then it's okay
that's a more favorable version of the
game we're probably not actually on the
a straight A three yeah I think I think
I probably have to improve here that
Queen c7 b5 isn't isn't any good a 97 is
the engine's choice and it makes a lot
of sense going here or here I need to
counter play against upon this looks
very okay actually for here so this is
what the engine is giving ya know
beatings yeah that's probably okay
interesting position bite has got space
but like it's got a good structure yeah
in the game Len was annoying when I also
spend far too much time c5 is of course
a very shaky move in the first place
yeah b3 is good against that so I should
have more precise it still seems to be
okay but it is a very very shaky
position now that that simply doesn't
work out I was just thinking about
sacrificing and then Queen e5 but he can
do it immediately
the position is however already pretty
bad now white yes a lot better okay guys
thanks for watching